das bin ich zwölf jahre alt und wie ihr
sehen könnt fühle ich mich gerade wieder
coolste typ eine ganze stadt weil ich
gerade zum ersten mal after effects
entdeckt habe aber ja wirklich mit
diesen klubs hat meine reise als visual
effects artist angefangen und sie sind
wunderschön anlässe zum neuen star wars
film nehme ich mir heute diesen clip und
noch zwei andere und versuche den wir
waren heutigen können nachzustellen um
einen vorher-nachher-vergleich zu haben
und um zu sehen ob es immer noch drauf
habt sowie mit 12 dieses video wird von
safe disk unterstützt der software die
steuern und buchhaltung endlich
erträglich macht wir sind heute wie
immer in meinem wunderschönen büro und
werden als allererstes mit den
dreharbeiten anfang dreharbeiten um die
chance möglichst cool zu machen brauchen
wir nämlich nicht nur bessere visual
effects sondern auch mit bessere kamera
wenn die klubs am anfang habe ich mit
dieser kamera aus dem jahre 2008 gemacht
mindestens genauso wichtig wie die
kamera ist das licht mit dem ich ein
bisschen herum experimentieren um eine
coole stimmung in das thema zu bringen
hier habe ich die franzi einen filzstift
benutzt für mein licht fällt aber für 9
euro habe ich mir von amazon cool das
licht wird geholt welches auch ausfahren
kann ich studiere hier zwar gerade genau
die bewegungen von dem altenclub 11 2008
zu machen habe ich aber dann später doch
dazu entschieden was cooleres zu machen
und bin ein spontan damit gelandet und
ich finde dass hier noch deutlich besser
aus
bevor wir zu den epischen lichteffekten
kommen geht es an die aufnahme des feuer
daumes
damit der minecraft schaut nicht so
gewackelt ist wie im original werde ich
hier für einen gimbel verwenden welches
mal eben aufgebaut ist und welches dazu
dienen soll die kamera möglichst gut zu
stabilisieren wie es gerade hier sieht
ist ein ganz wichtiges teil
zusätzlich habe ich ein externer monitor
damit ich oben sehen was die kamera und
alles aufnimmt
und hier sehen wir jetzt ein vergleich
links die gamble arbeit und rechts das
fertige video und ich finde dass es ein
bisschen besser geworden als vor zehn
jahren
und wir fangen auch direkt mit der
bearbeitung von diesem clip an und als
allererstes müssen wir die kamera treten
das bedeutet wir müssen die
kamerabewegung auffangen damit wir
einfach später ein objekt herr
einstellen können und deshalb dann am
boden bleibt ob das perfekte körper
testen jetzt auch in dem wir das im
kleinen dürfe reinstellen und das sieht
schon ziemlich cool aus ein teil wissen
wir dass es perfekt geklappt hat und wir
jetzt mal reinmachen könnt ich habe mich
dazu entschieden nicht so eine
langweilige grasfläche einzusetzen wie
das was ich von vor zehn jahren gemacht
habe sondern ich glaube mir was schönes
von der mep unseres minecraft server
projekt da ziehe ich mir die stadt pr
ausmacht in unser 3d programm rein
wundert mich dann für dieses
wunderschöne häuschen
der link zu minecraft server disco ist
übrigens in der beschreibung und jetzt
durch dieses haus schon in meinem zimmer
sind noch nicht ganz gut aus aber wenn
wir das ein bisschen um positionieren
und größer machen und raus ländern
das habe ich aber über nacht geändert
das was er jetzt gerade in zeitraffer
seht hat ein paar stunden gedauert jetzt
hat sich das haus meinen diese szene
rein und dann sehen wir jetzt da fiel
dennoch schalten und jetzt was viele von
euch nicht wissen viele denken man
erinnert direkt aus dem 3d programm das
fertige video raus aber das stimmt nicht
sondern man fügt später mehrere
schichten übereinander zum beispiel
schatten reflektion und so weiter und so
fort
in unserem fall haben wir jetzt hier zum
beispiel den wunderschönen schatten und
da setzen wir es gibt leute drauf und
auch ein bisschen fad anpassungen damit
unser haus auch wunderschön zum
hintergrund passt kann es ganz schön
geändert werden und wir haben dieses
wunderschöne haus was jetzt einfach so
in meinem zimmer drin steht kann ich bin
ziemlich geil wenn es einfach minecraft
haut im büro hier hinten drin und das
ist meiner meinung nach deutlich cooler
als die version von vor zehn jahren
und jetzt kommt meiner meinung nach das
kloster an wie die uns war der
lichtschwert schott ich glaube es
interessiert ziemlich viele von euch wie
die effekte von einem lichtschwert
gemacht werden und ich kann davor schon
dass viele von euch denken das wird
einfach direkt oder mit motion capturing
irgendwie gemacht dass ein automatischer
amazon laser dann drauf gebastelt wird
aber so machen wir das nicht die gängige
methode ist es nicht schon zu nehmen und
zwar nicht nur im griff weil dann muss
man ja schätzen wo der laser hinkommen
und das ist immer ziemlich ungenau
deswegen nimmt man so ein lichtschwert
was eben auch wirklich hier eine stange
daran hat damit wir auch genau wissen ob
da kommt der leser hin und diesen laser
den zeichnen wir jetzt mehr oder weniger
komplett manuell bild für bild mit maske
nein und das hat wirklich ziemlich
handelt
ihr fragt ihr euch jetzt vielleicht hat
er die maske so komisch dreieckig
gemacht weil so ein lichtschwert ist ja
nicht dreieckig und das liegt daran dass
ich das nicht sprechen gerade
schwungvoll bewegt habe und ich dann
dadurch durch diese breite die
bewegungsunschärfe darstelle was hier
auch ganz spannend dass die original
bewegungsunschärfe auf unserem echten
lichtschwert die gibt uns auch so ein
bisschen die richtung vor ihnen die wir
das letzte wort abschreiben können weil
ihr seht ihr hier zum beispiel dass es
hier große schreck zugeht so in
mühevoller kleinarbeit ist dann dieses
werk her entstanden haben ein weißes
licht statt da fehlt natürlich noch das
ganze leuchten was glaube ich auch
wirklich interessantes für euch und
viele vielleicht noch gar nicht wussten
so ein lichtschwert wird nicht einfach
die lauge fährt zum beispiel sondern
dieser kern eine sicht scherzt er bleibt
eigentlich immer weiß und außen rum wird
dann einfach nur die leute farbe an
wochen zugefügt das machen wir jetzt so
indem wir diesen licht kern ein paarmal
duplizieren und dann immer
unterschiedlich verschwommen machen
damit wir ebenso einen leichten verlauf
nach außen haben das dann eben aussieht
wie grün und damit haben wir zum glück
schwert war es einfach weiß ist und dass
vielleicht ein weißes lichtschwert auch
schon echt ziemlich geil wir färben dass
in dem fall noch ein bisschen rot ein
was finde ich für diesen sport einfach
am coolsten aussieht könnten das ganze
ist auch türkis machen oder hellblau und
das wird auch ziemlich geil aussehen wir
können jede farbe jetzt auswählen aber
ich habe ich hier für rot entschieden
und führt jetzt noch ein paar
lichteffekte hinzu wenn man es nicht
macht dann leuchtet würde ich so die
ganze gegend so ein bisschen und das
habe ich hier auch die zugefügt hat auch
so gemacht hast dieses lichtschwert so
ein bisschen flacher nicht immer gleich
ein erstes erkennt man vielleicht
bewusst gar nicht unbedingt aber runter
bewusst von der stadt ist fertig und
erinnert jetzt auch aber er wirkt noch
immer nicht richtig cool was da noch
viel das allerbeste und zwar die
lichtschwert sounds zum beispiel beim
anschalten des lichtschwert dieses
geräusch und dann beim bewegen des
lichts natürlich noch die geräusche
diese bewegung passen
und zusätzlich habe ich den ton auch
noch so eingestellt dass wenn das licht
schwer nach rechts geht dass ich dann
eben auch schon einer das wird vom
linken wandern
das ergebnis ist dann der schock hier
ich bin ganz ehrlich gesagt echt
überrascht von meiner performance also
diese bewegungen die habe ich komplett
spontan gemacht und wahrscheinlich denkt
jetzt voll peinlich
ich bin damit recht zufrieden dann fehlt
uns natürlich auch der feuer darum den
wir ein bisschen aufpassen müssen als
kind habe ich ja wirklich einfach ein
video von dem feuer auf meinen daumen
gelegt das problem dabei ist halt dass
ein feuer sich ja eigentlich wirklich
somit bewegt ja das hängt ja so
hinterher und dadurch wächst eben als
realistisch und um das wirklich
möglichst gut machen zu können müssen
wir das feuer selber erstellen und zwar
machen wir das mit partikeln das muss
ich euch jetzt nicht im detail erklären
man kann bei partikeln geben die anzahl
an stellen man kann einstellen die sich
die partikel bewegen wie viele partikel
es sind man kann da gewisse wind
widerstände hinzufügen man kann
einstellen dass sich die partikel
streuen und dann so hin und her wackeln
man kann einen schon dass ich langsam
unsichtbar werden und das dann eben auch
animieren so dass es außer das würden
die partikel wirklich durch luft oder
durch den echten wind cool beeinflusst
werden dann aktivieren wir noch die
bewegungsunschärfe bei den kritiken
damit diese ganzen einzelne punkte zu
schlieren zusammenwachsen die dann
wirklich aussehen wie so ein einzelnes
objekt und dann können wir hier die
farben jetzt grün sind auch cool aus ich
zu mir so schön orange ton aus und das
passt dann eben perfekt damit dieses
feuer licht aber irgendwo rum schwebt
müssen wir das jetzt auf dem daumen
setzen dazu dreckig jetzt den daumen
hier und zwar aufwändig manuell da ich
sie ja nicht anders wirklich schrecken
konnte weil der daumen eben nicht im
fokus ist und wirtschaft ist und dadurch
hatte ich nichts geht jetzt richtig gute
strecken und wenn wir jetzt ist feuer
draufsetzen dann finde ich das ein
bisschen zu sehr hinterher weil normal
geht dann feuer auch wenn man es bewegt
erstmal nach oben und dann zur seite und
hier geht es direkt zu blumen zur seite
und das finde ich halt nicht so cool
dann fügen wir noch ein bisschen rauch
und ein glühen hin zu animieren das
feuer an der stelle wo ich es aus puste
damit das ebenso breitgefächert wird und
einfach weggeht und haben dann auch
schon dieses ergebnis ich bin vor allem
auch den rauch hier ziemlich cool und
ihr seht jetzt ganz genau dass so ein
feuer eben hinterherhinken muss und
nicht an bord direkt auf seinen daumen
drauf sitzen muss ja es macht auf jeden
fall spaß diese ganzen chance nochmal
aufzuarbeiten denn das waren wirklich
die ersten paar shows die ich jemals mit
visual effects gemacht habt ich werde
auch wirklich oft gefragt ob ich das
ganze eine uni oder schule gelernt hab
jetzt wisst ihr dass ich das kann weil
ich das einfach als hobby schon extrem
früh angefangen habe und dann einfach
niemals aufgehört habt wie bereits am
anfang erwähnt wird dieses video
unterstützt von sap des heftes ist eine
software mit der selbstständige ganz
einfach in der buchhaltung und steuern
automatisieren können anstatt und leg
belege in unübersichtliche ordnung zu
sortieren scannt man sich mit step 1
oder welt sich von seinem computer aus
selbst als christ automatisch alle
wichtigen informationen wie zum beispiel
den betrag oder die rechnungsnummer
heraus und man hat direkt alle seine
belege kategorisiert und seine ausgaben
und einnahmen sowie an der einnahmen
überschussrechnung und weitere
statistiken klickt jetzt auf den link in
der video beschreibung und testet er ist
gratis für kirchentag wird natürlich
ohne irgendwelche zahlungsinformationen
angeben zu müssen
nächste woche am samstag kommt ein video
nämlich eine woche lang so lebe wie
ihren mast also wenn ihr das nicht
verpassen und mich auf meine reise
begleiten besitzt dann abonniert diesem
kanal und dann sehen wir zunächst mal
wieder macht's gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]